despite what the others say war is
inevitable yes i agree i must return to
aldridge i mean just i love it when just
political intrigue between these two
is happening in star wars
they did this so much better in rogue
one than they did in uh phantom menace
in my opinion
for sure and there was a deleted scene
with these two from revenge of the sith
that was a really cool scene so i think
this is a redemption for that
oh jimmy smits i would trust her with my
life
my precious adopted daughter who i was
told not to put in harm's way ever
sir so handle this send her along
she'll be fine she's a tough kid
the transmission we received yes yes
she'll be fine is it they've sent us
hope but how does she know who obi-wan
even is right
but
leia
are we coming back to this age of layup
yes we must we need to hello there
welcome back to new rock stars help us
obi-wan kenobi you're our only hope but
why did leia organa say those words was
there a history between this princess of
alderaan and obi-wan kenobi that we do
not know yet and will we see that
backstory on this season of
that'll never get old for me
never it'll just uh age like wine oh uh
uh i i just in my mind i realized there
was something that was that came up in a
meeting this week of like pitch like age
like other things and uh you may see it
on new rockstar so i don't want to spoil
it but uh it made me laugh it gave me a
mental giggle there yes a mental giggle
and whenever i'm not laughing out loud
tommy i'm doing mental giggles me too i
just want you to know that that's all i
internalize so much of my joy well this
is wikileaks our weekly reaction the
latest in star wars i'm eric voss uh
right now i am here chatting kenobi with
tommy bechtold oh yeah and i gotta say
after last week i went straight home and
i watched rogue one and then i watched a
new hope and i just bridged them
together i watched the last scene of
rogue one the first scene of a new hope
and it was like oh so good it was like a
little hot fudge sundae for my eyes it
was wonderful
oh just seeing those let's see how many
engines eleven engines
for twelve engines on the table
it's four three four four four four just
seeing those together and a completely
unnecessary number of engines on on just
a passenger cruiser yeah but i love
seeing it it worked it's that guy in
your town that makes his car way too
loud because he wants like everyone to
know where he's kind of like it's like
it's like a ford taurus but he
supercharged it and put like way too big
of an engine in it it's that guy that's
what that that's what that passenger
ship is
i agree now tommy and i were chatting
before we started rolling about how like
we're surprised how many of you are
joining us every week for uh for this
show we love being able to do this and
we thank you so so much for tuning in
every week we're going to do our best to
try to answer your star wars questions i
mean right now we're we're in kind of a
dune sea of of star wars content there's
little news trickling out here and there
we still don't have a kenobi trailer but
the fact that you guys are still eager
to hear me and tommy yeah
gab about
jabba or whatever jabba jabber is what
we have in script here but we never
actually
have a jabba
yoga pajama
uh i i just have to say eric you know
these dune seas though they are sandy
we're once covered in water and and we
are perhaps providing the moisture
we're getting the people wet
with enthusiasm
over the over over the star wars content
and for that i'm grateful that's right
we're keeping the tap running we're
keeping the water warm we should say
right yes
uh but just with our body heat that's
the secret of our hot tub is it's just
us baby there's no jets running that's
right that's dust but you know this dry
spell may be coming to a close because
the word on the street is we may be
seeing a trailer for obi-wan kenobi
any day now in fact maybe this week we
will see so until that trailer starts to
answer our questions about the series
maybe bring some more questions we want
to explore one more rumor that has
gotten us very excited for obi-wan
kenobi that young leia could appear on
this series could we finally get the
answer to the mystery of how leia knew
obi-wan kenobi not just through her
father telling her that he is her only
hope but these two might have met before
this um before we saw this moment in
rogue one and then of course when they
when they came together in a new hope
that's what we'll explore on today's
episode but first we want to thank our
merch partners at epic hero shop for
giving us a new batman inspired latest
obsession shirt you can check that out
over at epic heroshop.com or
newrockstarsmerch.com it's a really
really cool shirt i'm not wearing it now
because i i wore it all weekend for my
batman videos and i sweated through that
because i'm you know just feeling that
heat from that bat signal you know just
i'm sizzling sizzling so i sweat
straight through that thing it's in the
in the laundry uh but as a reminder all
the releases in the latest obsession
series have been big hits and eventually
they sell out so you gotta head on over
to epic hero shop.com grab one for
yourself before they are gone uh
eric
will obi-wan kenobi feature young leia
well a reminder that obi-wan kenobi is
taking place in 9 bby that's 10 years
after revenge of the sith nine years
before a new hope so leia is going to be
about 10 years old at the time of this
series there were some rumors last july
that a young leia was cast for kenobi
maybe with actress vivian lira blair
that's the girl from bird box if you
remember that movie cannot confirm that
to be true yet we will see uh major
media outlets we're not confirming that
it's just a rumor but uh this era of
leia's life has been largely unexplored
in live action star wars after the clone
wars leia of course was adopted by
senator bail organa jimmy smits we're
schmidt spitting for smith's meeting my
mouth baby i'm ready for you
he's he's uh that guy will age uh so
well that he's gonna if he shows up on
obi-wan kenobi as we expect him to yeah
he's gonna look so good compared to
every other actor they're also they're
gonna be like we don't need to do any
technology to you
you're fine yeah you're good you look
the same
however the makeup person did him in the
heights is exactly he looked literally
no different than 20 years ago we're
just going to hear a bell from a door
opening and a bodega and he's going to
say good morning
[Laughter]
one mega lotto ticket please
theater kids talking about star wars
theater kids a galaxy far away
[Music]
away
well after the loyal people have stuck
with us this far have all clicked away
understandably we lost them thinking
back up with what happened with adopted
leia so yeah uh bale adopted her along
with his wife breja uh the queen of um
uh alderaan and leia's youth was
explored and actually a few materials
that are still currently considered to
be star wars canon uh like the 2015
junior novel retelling of a new hope
called the princess scoundrel on the
farm boy and that we learned how leo as
a kid actually preferred shooting
lessons to her royal etiquette training
from her many aunts and uh she heard
stories from baylor ghana about the jedi
and about darth vader she learned to
despise
tarkin
which is why she was so disgusted with
him in a new hope um and then there was
a 2019 comic called so much more in
which breha told leia about amidala of
naboo she finds her reading at the base
of the statue she's like who is this
woman and she tells her all about
padme's importance eventually to the
rebellion as this independent senator
who spoke out against what was happening
in the senate but she stopped short of
telling her that padme wasn't her
biological
biological mother really her youth is
explored the most in the 2017 book by
claudia gray called leia princess of
alderaan set when leia turns 13 and she
uh really enters the political world of
the legislative apprenticeship she meets
eventual political allies like mon
mothma as well as the young amelin holdo
and she finally learns that her parents
are part of the rebellion that was a
secret kept from her until she was 16.
uh and then by the end of that book she
herself joins the rebellion and vows to
to help these uh rebel
missions and actually we see her a few
years after that in star wars rebels
season two episode 12 a princess long a
princess on lothal uh this would be
about two years before a new hope or so
and in this episode leia escorts three
cruisers to low fall and stage is a kind
of con to make it look like those
cruisers got stolen by the rebels when
in fact she was actually working with
them uh but she couldn't look like she
was directly helping them she had to
make it look like they were on opposite
sides
so if she does show up on this show at
age 10 this should be before leia learns
about bail organa's allegiance to the
rebellion and therefore she shouldn't
really meet obi-wan kenobi right because
obi-wan is really at this point in
history a super wanted fugitive in the
eyes of the empire and in the eyes of
the inquisitors uh it'd be like a kid
during the war on terror uh hanging out
with osama bin laden uh and then like
that kid would probably know who osama
bin laden is even if you know her
parents were actually working for al
qaeda and she didn't know that look i'm
making some problematic comparisons to
the rebels in al-qaeda but they are
supposed to be terrorists at least in
the eyes of the empire it's just
terrorists doing good stuff you know
yeah yeah terrorists doing good stuff
that's like the pilot we wrote remember
where we tried to paint terrace in a
sympathetic light we were gonna try and
change the narrative and then people
said eric tommy this will kill your
careers and we said we don't care and we
mailed them in suspicious packages to
all the major studio heads right in
hindsight that was a bad move by us it
was in hindsight especially to pitch it
the day after 9 11. we were really
confident in that idea but 9 12. who
could forget
uh
snip all that out if you want guys no
leave it in i will quit i will walk off
this job if you leave it in and then all
the editors are like yeah leave it in
bury these foot
but anyway yes if leia were to have met
obi-wan kenobi yeah that would have been
like she would have known how big of a
deal that was um because at that point
she did not know what her parents were
really doing that they were involved
with the rebels that they were old
friends and still good friends with this
person so if she met obi-wan kenobi at
age 10 in this show it would likely be
in some scenario where she actually
learns his relationship with bale and
bale's true loyalties it would have to
do a bit of a retcon to that 2017 book
so if young leia is in the series i
think it'll either be in a scenario
where obi-wan interacts with her without
revealing his true identity like where
he's disguised or revealing his history
with her parents or they're gonna wreck
on that 2017 book i just assume the
former that for now maybe some part of
this series will show obi-wan disguised
either masked or just like he looks
different enough that you know they
don't she doesn't know him really right
like she doesn't have like maybe she
does it yeah maybe maybe like the like
obi-wan kenobi isn't like uh a serious
black wanted posters everywhere
but like he's just someone that even the
empire through their propaganda has just
like tried to erase and has only
equipped the inquisitors to try to hunt
down that former jedi because his
survival might make them look bad and if
solo a star wars story taught us
anything it's that the empire is very
self-aware of their branding including
the imperial marks being their actual
theme song for for their for their
recruitment video videos
yeah agreed um now really there are all
kinds of ways this kenobi series could
change our understandings of obi-wan's
time during this period in star wars
history like if he leaves tatooine at
all in this series it's gonna seem like
a pretty big contradiction of his vow to
yoda to look after luke skywalker we've
always assumed especially when maul
caught up with obi-wan in rebels that
obi wan just spent all of that time on
tattooing just getting old just going by
the name ben kenobi getting a reputation
is just this weird loner exile that's uh
living where he's living in beggars
canyon so like the fact that he would
have other adventures where he left this
sandy planet is just going to be
interesting i kind of want that to be
the case but it does kind of force the
question of who's gonna be looking after
luke during that time while he's gone uh
he's gonna need some kind of babysitter
to make sure luke stays okay i'm
thinking maybe force ghost qui-gon could
do that and alert him like it's like
kind of a baby monitor or maybe ahsoka
tano the only issue there is it would
mean rosario dawson would return and
play ahsoka 20 years younger than the
age she plays the character in the
mandalorian and boba fett but you know
like jimmy smits rosario dawson does not
age only looks uh uh handsomer and
prettier those two as as the years go on
must be nice it must be nice it must be
nice anyway i'm sorry yeah lin-manuel
just is gonna creep back into this
episode multiple times we can't avoid it
we can't keep them out we can't keep
them out we're going to talk about bruno
razor glass razor glass to him huh
so i guess my question for you tommy is
how bad would things have to get for
young leia for obi-wan to leave behind
luke on tatooine like is leia gonna need
to get rescued is she gonna get ensnared
some in some civil war conflict that
obi-wan will need to intervene in but do
it in some kind of subtle way that
doesn't reveal his jedi history or
perhaps will some inquisitor discover
the lineage connection between leia and
luke and vader and obi-wan is going to
need to take out that inquisitor to keep
the secret buried i absolutely love that
idea i so here's the thing obi-wan and
leia kind of have a complicated
relationship even just looking in the
films if you think about like
uh empire strikes back
obi-wan kind of i mean i know that
granted this was like the early 80s and
maybe the mentality was like we've got
to keep these stories male protagonist
driven but at one point he laments to
yoda that luke is their only hope
despite knowing that leia exists it has
to be reminded by yoda that like no
there's a whole other person that could
also
that has these force probably force
abilities and force sensitivities
they're going to have to redo a lot of
that like obi-wan is going to have to
have this sudden appreciation for leia
that he hasn't just demonstrated before
the thing i really like though
that i had talked about before and that
you're talking about here now is the
idea of maybe him moving around leia to
keep her safe without her having
anywhere there won't be a direct
uh interaction between them but he will
obi-wan will intervene to keep her alive
and keep her safe without her having any
knowledge that he was there almost like
a like a shadow protector you know like
i think that yeah what am i thinking of
there's like a cartoon where there's
like a baby crawling and there's like
someone who's like oh yeah like a cat or
something that's yeah keep them safe
where what am i thinking of oh i guess
it's kind of like who framed roger
rabbit a little bit that's what i was a
baby opening scene and the baby like all
the knives are flying around yes um it
is kind of that like the oblivious it's
almost what like the mandalorians
started as right like
baby yoda's getting into trouble and
then amanda's like
like keeping pianos from falling on him
i like the idea though of the mystery of
the skywalker family could be could have
been uncovered much earlier only to be
foiled by obi-wan like you know like
only to be only to have obi-wan prevent
that knowledge from reaching them like
almost in a selfish way like in you know
what i mean like him being like
this will create too much of a mess
almost still perhaps in a way to
preserve luke's safety like he's like
leia can't find out that vader is her
father because then she'll go find luke
so he has to like keep her from knowing
this i like that i think that i think
that that would be a really cool way to
do that i i yeah i just don't know i'm
so fascinated by how these new shows can
can develop and evolve these characters
it's such a cool opportunity because
like i said
when you watch the original trilogy
you're like obi-wan doesn't think
anything of leia really you know he's
just kind of like
she's just the prince i mean he he
respects her as like a princess and as a
dignitary but he's not like she's
definitely not on equal footing with
luke like he's like luke is our savior
right and that's why like you touch on
something i i love empire strikes back
it'll always be in my top three of star
wars films and it's one of my like top
10 movies um but the reason why i think
i'll always lean to a new hope just
being a more purely structured film that
i'll always like a bit more as empire
starts to do a bit more world building
and franchise building that just feels
uh not sloppy but just feels a little a
little forced uh and i think that moment
was one it felt so cryptic and cool but
it forces us to like blame obi-wan for
stuff that's not really his fault it's
like it's just like george lucas it's
larry kasten just trying to do their
best
but like when george says that he had
all this figured out and outlined when
he first wrote the first script for star
wars i don't buy it he made some changes
over time which is okay for creatives
well why would you not once i mean once
once you see how people if you put a
piece of art out into the world and see
how people react it's human nature to be
like let me make some tweaks to keep
this reaction positive most people
aren't andy kaufman antagonizing people
with their art at all costs like
i i don't think uh they knew at that
point that leia was going to be revealed
i think they the idea was there was
another could have referred to a couple
different other things i'm sure there
are interviews out there that i'm
forgetting where they said what they
intended there was another to be but i
don't think they knew at that point that
leia was going to be revealed they did
have that moment i guess at the end of
empire where leia sensed uh luke calling
out to her maybe you could make an
argument there that that for sure meant
that they were gonna be siblings or that
she was just another force sensitive
person who is somehow connected to this
i don't know if we should blame obi-wan
for that i know that's what we try to do
at new rockstars is not like antagonize
the creatives the directors the
screenwriters make this stuff by like
framing it as a character
choice as opposed to a stupid obi-wan
kenobi that sentient character who made
that choice you know who i blame sir
alec guinness
exhume his body and put him on trial
i mean famously it's that whole scene
was uh i believe a certain point of view
came earlier in the movie right no that
was that scene um but it was when luke
took off when he said uh he was our last
hope right yes he leaves dagger by to go
save
try and save han and leia yeah before
his training was completed yeah i think
the line from a certain point of view
just kind of was supposed to justify all
of it and the reason that luke was not
told that darth vader was his dad uh we
don't find that out until of course at
the end of empire um was that they
didn't want him to confront vader that
soon that's why yoda didn't want him to
leave dagobah is he tried to scare him
with you know his own face under his
father's mask like you're not ready
you're not ready to confront this guy
yet and it's it's gonna be bad you're
gonna lose one of your friends uh or
he'll just be frozen in carbon night and
he can thaw him out later but um i think
to answer the question of like leia on
this show i think we are hearing some
rumors that like rupert friend who is
the guy from homeland if you watch
homeland he was like the dude on that
show he's awesome um he might be playing
the grand inquisitor um who's gonna be
discovering obi-wan and i assume that
he would be this interesting antagonist
that obi-wan would be afraid of uh
catching luke and leia i think at that
point obi-wan is not interested in
self-preservation as much as he is the
preservation of the people he vowed to
protect absolutely for from his point of
view uh
his life is essentially over he's fought
all of his battles he's one final
mission is to make sure these kids are
going to be okay or this one kid is
going to be okay and that's why he's
okay to give his life on the death star
yeah i don't need to live anymore i'm
good i'm good if obi-wan's life is
threatened i think as long as he would
have like some other babysitter to fill
in for him and look after luke i think
it's okay so if you're gonna challenge a
guy who no longer has self-preservation
as his number one priority you gotta
threaten the kids uh and i think that
grand inquisitor discovering that
connection you gotta imagine if you're a
grand inquisitor you're a former jedi
who's trying who's tasked with hunting
down other jedi if you discover that
basically the boss
has this dark secret that could be
embarrassing to him
don't you think he would keep that from
him at first to say like look i found it
i took care of it don't worry about it
if he were to bring it to him he might
be like he's this [ __ ] is going
to force choke me if i if you're right
yeah absolutely like you could imagine
darth vader
i think that could end up being uh
something that happens that would be the
one thing they could imagine obi-wan
being like
okay look by the way an inquisitor
horror movie people are getting carved
in half by lightsabers but like but like
vertically would be incredible like like
a hard r gory inquisitor like just like
almost like an alien it takes place on
one ship with an inquisitors going
around murdering people would be
incredible deborah chao if you're
listening there's still time but i mean
i think that's the thing this has got to
be the show that introduces uh live
action viewers to inquisitors i mean
people who watched uh rebels know full
well how
cool and terrifying inquisitors are
but it's time for live action to
understand that because we haven't
really seen that and we didn't see that
on mandalorian of course or boba fett
that's well after the galactic civil war
so the fact that this is a one live
action series we know about that's
returning that period this is we got to
see them we got to see them before we
continue with some uh predictions for
what we think is going to be in this
first obi-wan kenobi teaser we want to
thank our friends at peloton for
sponsoring this episode one of your
biggest enemies to getting fit is
boredom doing the same workout over and
over can sap your motivation to exercise
and hurt your progress and that's where
our friends at peloton can help with
their awesome peloton app you don't need
to own one of the cool peloton bikes to
use this app for classes and workouts
they have new classes new music and new
ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating peloton has a workout for
every day and every schedule de-stress
from a long day with 30 minutes of
strength and 20 minutes of cardio or do
a quick 15-minute total body class
before work you stay motivated while
having fun with bike workouts yoga
meditation dance cardio and more they
have some really cool boxing classes
that i'm excited to try out you don't
need to have ever boxed before you don't
even need to have gloves more than like
you know the power ranger gloves that i
still have that make
oh you want to punch those my hulk hands
i use my hulk hands hulk smash
you can build up an excellent sweat
while learning the fundamentals of
boxing and channeling your inner
welterweight champion you could use the
app on all of your devices play it on
your tv to work out in the living room
or bring your phone or tablet out into
the yard for some sun and sweat outdoors
if you want to add some great motivating
variety to your workouts check out the
peloton app by clicking the link in the
video's description or visit
onepeloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
dot-com
any day now we could get the obi-wan
kenobi teaser uh i'm so excited for this
it's gonna be a game changer so i wanna
know from you let's make some
predictions of what will and won't won't
be
be in this kenobi trailer if it drops
this week let's talk about do we think
we're gonna see hayden christensen
either under the mask or with the mask
off are we gonna see the fate of the
scarred face of having i don't think we
get a face reveal yet i think we get a
vader i think we get images of vader i
don't think we get a face reveal yet
here here's here's what here's my take
on like
what star wars likes to do in trailers
and i say i know i say this to the man
who breaks them down better than anyone
in the biz baby
but one thing that star wars can't help
themselves is an audio reveal in the
trailer whether it's a heavy breathing
vader and a rogue one or a palpatine
cackle
in a uh
whatever what was the last one rise of
skywalker
i think we're gonna get maybe a
hayden christensen kind of like force
ghost voice over a vader image that's
that that's my prediction i also think
we're going to get at the end of the
trailer
a qui-gon voice i think that's going to
be the fade out it's going to be the
reveal that liam neeson is coming back
as a quiet guy and i think it'll be like
something like hello old friend i've
been taken see
i i think we may if if this trailer does
tease that moment i think it would be
it'd almost be like you and turn around
being like
it's been too long old friend yeah i
don't know if we would see maybe a soft
blue glow on his face you know like i
don't know if we would blue glow
oh my god i would cry if he turned
around and there was just a soft little
blue glow it's max rebo with a with a
flashlight i can't die
i can never die
i'll max
[Laughter]
that's who benny safety is playing right
at coked out max repo oh he better he
better be yeah i don't want to see benny
play anything else um but speaking of
blue glows uh do you think we will see
the ignition of anakin's lightsaber i
mean a kenobi teaser like we may see
several lightsabers igniting right like
that's kind of right yeah that's i mean
the ew and mcgregor kenobi i feel like
established
how important the lightsaber is to the
character maybe a little more than poor
sir alec guinness
hey he did he did what he was told oscar
nominated i think the only star wars
actor to be oscar nominated he did great
i love ella guinness bridge over river
kwai one of my favorite star wars movies
okay uh next thing do you think we might
see the planet of alderaan in this
trailer you know we we know we're not
gonna get to see it forever so i'd
certainly like a few more glimpses
glimpses of alderaan i mean that would
definitely to me be a pretty clear key
that we're going to see a young leia
then right like why show alderaan yeah
you know yeah i think like the
inquisitors this is the one opportunity
for star wars and live action to really
show us i guess any point before it
explodes we could see alderaan in the
past before the galactic civil war but i
think it'd be fascinating just to go
there and see topographically what it
looked like and uh
and just show us what we lost when
tarkin blew it up and i agree if we see
it we're probably gonna see young leia
um do you think we will see i i have to
assume we'll see camille non-gianni's
character in this right like disney
loves to put camille in a trailer oh
yeah
especially we don't know how muscular he
is for this one yet i think he shot this
after he shot eternal so i have to
imagine this is just like chris pratt
this is permanent camille now that's
right now he is now only brick [ __ ]
kumal he's no longer we'll never we'll
never see doughy comedian kumal again
and then uh i guess lastly are we gonna
see any kind of tease of the duel
between obi-wan and vader are we gonna
see lightsabers clash i don't know
because if this is the only trailer
we're getting then yes but it presumably
will get more we'll get another trailer
right before right i think well i think
we'll get at least two yeah so then i
don't think so not in the first one i'm
saying no all right well we will find
out hopefully this week we'll get our
obi-wan kenobi trailer uh and we'll
check in afterwards to see how how right
we were how wrong i was
and how wrong
usually how wrong i am as well
but uh that is it for this week on
wikileaks don't forget to check out our
many great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com or epikiroshop.com
follow me at ea bots follow tommy and
tommy beck told follow new rockstars
subscribe to new just
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts thank you for watching and
goodbye then
you